identitarianism is one of the biggest
things that i have a problem with due to
my
my my family history being i know it's
kind of a meme but mixed
and this comes from when we look at
affirmativeness
isn't that identity politics you're
saying your view on this is informed
you're against identity politics
as informed by your identity
yeah it it is what it is the aclu when
they supported affirmative action at
harvard which lumps all asians indian
chinese laotians into one category and i
find that offensive as an asian person
and so when i come out and say tim tim
that's an identity
to say you should be able to argue
whether it's offensive or not offensive
right or not right
without saying because you are part
asian you fight like
that's identity politics which you claim
to be against i no i agree i think i
think the clarification then i think
what we're discovering here
is that it's not so much the core idea
of identity politics it's the
application of
in ways that either is reductive or
authoritarian everything you're building
here right now right
do you want the government to tell you
how to do all these things and all the
regulations that you got to have your
electric thing this far from this and
like all that the regulations like that
for construction are important though
you do have to make sure that people
don't do stupid [ __ ]
but i mean i don't have it's near a
water line
yeah there's a lot of but i would put
most of that on the builders though they
want to build things that are good now i
get it
oh that's not true listen people don't
know people are going to corners
all the time like you have to have
regulations when it comes to
construction methods or people are going
to get [ __ ]
they cut regulate they cut corners when
there are regulations anyway
they do they would cut a lot more if
there weren't regulations i'm not
talking to third world countries and
look at construction methods they're
[ __ ] dangerous yeah that's why
schools collapse on kids in foreign
countries sometimes like
well i'm not complete i'm not telling
you that i'm against all regulation
period that's where
but that's where i said intellectually i
like that argument because you could
make us
i think you can make a very sound
argument that competition would force
people
to do better work like if you're a
plumber you have a vested interest
in doing the best plumbing job you can
so that people will rate you on yelp
so that you will get more work you don't
have a vested interest in cutting
corners now you might right you're going
to push it as much as you can
to save as much time and energy and
money as you can but once you go over
that edge yeah you don't want to be
known as the guy that the
you tighten something too much so that
you flooded the house or when you're
building a house you're thinking
logically though when when people [ __ ]
things up and short things and do things
terrible they're not thinking logically
but i don't think it's the government
i don't think it's the government that
they're like ah the government gave me
this regulation so that's why i'm gonna
do it right
well if they didn't have any regulations
there'd be no incentive whatsoever to do
it right no there would be an incentive
they knew there were no
inspectors no one was going to check
their stuff and make sure that their
stuff was up to code
listen man i was in construction my
whole life my dad was an architect
i've been in construction since i was a
little kid you [ __ ] need
regulations these guys a lot of people
that are in construction
they're they'll do whatever the [ __ ]
they can to make money and it's not good
for the people that have the house
because
they might have that house for five ten
years before that problem manifests
itself
hillary trump seems to me that you've
you bashed hillary
now you're trying to back off a little
bit are you saying that trump an unknown
quantity
is more dangerous than a known crook
so first of all dinesh you keep calling
her a crook
but you just got out of jail
why don't you should let's uh let's give
dinesh a second why don't you tell us
i agree so this is an important point
i agree uh i agree just explain to us
what exactly happened with that
i just want to live on my land and be
completely self-sufficient
and not pay your taxes after three years
the town would come kick you off of your
property and seize your land
how would you know it's your land how
would you prove that it's your land
well in theory you would have a property
deed because that's what happens when
you buy property
who would issue the property
well right now there are governments
that issue those things
and what i'm saying is we're talking
about the current paradigm
of how could you own land and there are
things
right now that exist when you go by land
you get a deed
for the last right if you're talking
about what would happen in a free
society then there would be
competing agencies probably that would
issue such
deeds which one would you you're asking
me to centrally planned liberty
and that's not what i'm interested in
what i'm interested in wait a second i
want to hear about that
right hold on sam hold on
let me finish my thought and if you keep
trying to piss me off i will disconnect
from the call
so you're asking me to centrally plan
liberty i'm not interested in centrally
planning liberty i'm interested
in promoting the idea of human freedom
okay so so wait a second i'm sorry i
didn't mean to upset you
i'm just trying to figure i think you
absolutely did mean to upset me
no i i think you absolutely do want to
try to
push me into a corner to where you can
say see you don't have the answers of
how freedom works
damn it sam nobody has all the answers
on how freedom works
that's why freedom is so important
because
people should have the right to make
decisions that
other people might not agree with that's
why i support freedom that's why i
love freedom well daryl because i'm
smart enough to know that i don't know
how to run your life
and i think the democrats they didn't i
don't think they tried to flip the
results in 2016 for the most part there
were there was a whole lot of that
hillary can still win stuff
hillary conceded the next day but
absolutely not even remotely similar
uh it's remotely similar i would say
it's maybe like the way that antarctica
is remotely close to like please do you
see the videos of celebrities saying the
electoral college must
vote for hillary clinton do you think
there's a difference well i'm sorry they
didn't say that they think there's
anything between celebrities saying
something and the president of the
united states trying to undermine the
election
that's why i think these aren't remotely
similar yes under mine see that's that's
that's framing
well it's when you say 2016 trump said
millions of illegals voted he asserted
that with no evidence that's undermining
the integrity of election
and then in 2020 he's saying that there
was widespread election fraud that
literally no agency no other credible
person has backed up saved for
the melting of giuliani like no one else
is backing up on this
his own dhs turned on him on this with
his own appointee
his own attorney general the sword and
shield what did he say barr
came out and said that as of right now
there is no evidence of widespread
election fraud
if you look at the second amendment the
second amendment doesn't guarantee a
right to own a warship
right it doesn't guarantee your right to
own a cannon even even but hold on a
second one of the main tenets of those
who are constitutionalist is that
the constitution only says what you
can't do and the second amendment
doesn't say you can't own a warship
no correct the second amendment
no that's that that is true the second
amendment is negative right so in other
words it's not actually you're wrong on
that
obviously it's a very simple argument
from my point of view and that is that
people if they have the right to bear
arms in order to prevent tyranny
then that that goes for arms to prevent
the that goes to the the ultimate limit
of that
is the arms necessary to prevent
basically you can own any arm
that is necessary to necessary
not really to prevent tyranny well this
is good because in waco texas the in
waco texas
in waco texas the government used tanks
isn't it then reasonable to say
people need tanks because they were used
in waco texas
because this is the balance that we draw
right and this is and this is true for
all legislators it's totally subjective
though ben
it's not totally subjective the fact is
that if you if you disarm a population
of rifles there is no chance that it
could be a popular resistance to tyranny
period
and if you if you only give them rifles
and the tanks roll out the rifles are
useless
guys that's the death penalty i just
want to say that i'm so pro-life
you know i'm against this people i love
the death penalty
process which unfortunately one i think
will party in this country
so as a man so so then you're against
the autonomous vehicle
let's just cut through the talking
points because yeah let's let's
[ __ ] process you're against gitmo
guys guys if you're
[Applause]
going to step in here this foreign going
to be easy if he keeps walking right
into the trap like that
so but another thing that we we just
wrote about and again people get mad
with the wheat issues
well no no traffic fatalities regarding
marijuana have skyrocketed
google that because that's nonsense no
okay but there have been tests where
they showed people
but that would go back to what he said
there have been tests where they've
shown people drunk versus on marijuana
and the people on marijuana drove
far better okay that's true so this is
also anecdotal
no are it goes back to your point right
let's say someone has alcohol are these
tests
well i don't i haven't read your test
okay so why are you arguing against them
no i'm saying i agreed with your point
earlier so why are you saying there are
let me know
well it is anecdotal if you're saying
some people drive better on maryland no
i'm not saying that i've said there have
been tests
where they've shown that people drive
better on marijuana than alcohol
my point is you're looking to be really
good at this argument no no
no no no you just settle down you said
you wouldn't pile on and you got two
people and then
when someone comes on the show jared
cannot entertain congratulations you're
not on the show
and all he did was pull up some [ __ ]
people bringing up information me
without a laptop no he brought
you said what would be the one thing
that you've changed your mind is there a
problem when two people are correct and
you're incorrect does that bother you
i don't agree that you're correct what
are you talking about you just pulled up
some statistics that show that colorado
has less
traffic
utilitarianism versus deontologism that
you you're quantifying versus i'm not
you see that i'm not saying you're wrong
i'm saying
your philosophical standard is the
minimization of harm and mine is
more about the individual is the small
you know what i mean like
yeah i'm curious about the second part
of that you said you know what i mean
because i really don't
oh so minimize the two philosophies
about feeling violating the ethics of an
individual
is violating ethics regardless and yours
is minimization of harm is better so
utilitarian
versus deontological from my standpoint
committing one unethical act
is a violation of principle and ethics
that can't be crossed but i will admit
there's not like a hard line because
you know um i think that is silly
to be honest with you i mean i i respect
you you know but they're very strong
philosophical uh positions hello
most people that i i believe that
less suffering is better and that i am
willing
to i'll i'll i will tell you something
you won't like to hear though i'm
willing to
shuffle myself if that that's the
outcome but
i'll tell you something you're not going
to want to hear and and i admit it's
it's uh i'll call it dickish uh
utilitarianism is typically the villain
in most movies i don't care
yeah so so for instance like thanos was
the was utilitarian and captain america
was deontological
i didn't so thanos willing to reduce the
suffering by killing
you know hundreds of trillions versus
the you know thousands of trillions
which would be living better off
there was a testimony before congress
from l.a communities where black
witnesses were going in saying
my kid applied to the local mcdonald's
they wouldn't hire him because he didn't
speak spanish
it is mostly black communities that are
being
overwhelmed with illegal immigrants and
to be mocking them and saying they're
afraid of spanish people
i think is very dismissive and insulting
well here's what happens in this free
hold on
you like the free market right you love
the free market i love the free market
as well
as long as you don't have let me finish
my point
keep going okay um in a free market
uh of course there will be competition
for certain jobs
right and so the most skilled worker is
likely to get that position being
bilingual
is a skill you're able to communicate
and and i get it if you're not bilingual
it makes you uncomfortable
you're not as competitive but guess what
you know we live in a country where you
have all the resources at your
fingertips you can learn a language for
free online
and so enough with this victimhood
because i feel like there's a lot of
victimhood coming from you right now
right if you want to compete for these
jobs go out there and learn
pick yourself up by the bootstraps learn
a new language there's nothing wrong
with knowledge
but none of that matters because the
climate hysteria movement is not about
science
if it were about science it would be led
by scientists rather than by politicians
and a mentally ill swedish child who is
being exploited by her parents
and by the international where are you
so what you're seeing here is a
political movement
and a religious movement and it's a
fulfilling
religious and political goals of the
left but it isn't doing very much for
science
chris you had a visceral reaction to
that go ahead
yeah i mean you're a grown man and
you're attacking a child
shame on you she's trying to do it
attacking the left right
relax skinny boy i got this okay
you're attacking a child you're a grown
man
have some kind i'm not i'm attacking
maybe on your maybe on your podcast you
get away and say whatever you want
because nobody's listening
you're on national television be a
grown-up when you're talking about
children she's trying to save the planet
because your president
doesn't believe in climate change and
kids need to take to the streets to
worry about their future
you are despicable for talking to her
about her like that you should apologize
on national television
right now i think the the international
left and her parents who are exploiting
a girl with many mental illnesses you
called her
mentally ill take it back now she is
taking it back now she is mentally ill
she has taken
she has obsessive compulsive disorder
she has selective views
she had depression despicable
and that war was over in 1945. civil war
was over in 1865 and we are still at the
effect of this
underlying stuff that we we move on from
one generation to another
but do you think there's apologize well
do you think there's a little bit of a
risk in
in sort of i mean a couple of times
you're referencing the genocide of the
jews to slavery seems like a little bit
of a
a slippery slope there now i don't even
know how we can say that actually and i
say that as a jew
have you read up much on slavery yeah
we're talking abject slavery day
i mean nobody's in a contest nobody has
a monopoly on human suffering
this was abject slavery million and also
if you started slavery
in 1619 and you had two and a half
years two two and a half centuries
and then at the end there were four to
five million enslaved people
do you realize generation after
generation how many millions of people
were talking about
right well i'm not diminishing that but
you can also talk about the
extermination of six million people and
the amount of
people that never lived because of that
that would be alive
or your ancestors from well from russia
who were never given anything and came
here
well wait a minute wait a minute but the
germans have paid reparations that's
kind of my point
the fact that germany paid reparations
germany has done full-on maricopa
uh it seems like everyone's kind of
veering to some version of open borders
that that's
somehow something kind of okay so tell
me
where do you get that well i don't
consider i'm a democrat no no i don't
consider
myself a democrat anymore i don't
consider myself a republican but i'm
definitely not a democrat
i have not heard one candidate well they
won't say it but
but the policies seem oh oh you don't
say it but you really
mean is it is that is that healthy
honorable debate you say it if you
believe it i don't believe
you can have healthy no i i i take them
at their word
what has trump done to make it easier
for
businesses to get going by cutting back
on so many
rules and regulations that the democrat
had established
like what what's an example of such a
such a rule i don't have anything in
mind
right now yeah but a lot of the rules of
regulation that was preventing
uh uh small businesses from starting
yeah have been taken away by the great
white hope what would be but so give me
just i don't i know that there's dozens
and dozens but what's
one such rule that was taken away that
now makes it easier to start a business
nothing come to mind right now it is
there anything that you can remember
even seeing at any time nothing come
tomorrow
nothing wow that's amazing amazing
yeah your book is uh a criticism of uh
how angry america is and how america has
to do better
and i'm sure i have an entire list on my
website sir sir on my list i have an
entire website
i'm trying to point out some of the
things you you've said that
seem to me to help to stalk that anger
for example you said
sure israelis like to build arabs like
to bomb
crap and live in open sewage
well as i say in an article entitled
here's a list of all the giant bad dumb
things i've ever said
was that was that well yes that's a dumb
tweet and not only
but it is also important to mention that
the next few tweets clarify that that
tweet is specifically referring to the
hamas leadership
which by the way a bbc i've seen is
relatively reticent to condemn
no actually it wasn't what you went on
to do and say
you are correct about the slur and arabs
it's not all arabs that want to live in
open sewage and blow things up
it's just palestinians even on to say
holiday no
no the ones who take sides against
israel the israel palestinian population
is rotten to the core you went on to say
not hamas arab population
frankly i find this whole thing a waste
of time if you want to read the book and
critique the book why don't you read and
critique the book if you want to re if
you want to critique me
you can think whatever you want of me
why don't you drink trying i don't care
i don't
you know i i'm not inclined to continue
an interview with a person as badly
motivated as you as an interviewer so i
think we're done here i appreciate your
time
all right well thank you for your time
and uh for showing that anger is not
part of american
political discourse now mr shapiro will
say goodbye we have to care about the
environment it was progress and it's
like no like we've been losing america
has been
losing and donald trump understood that
in a way that i didn't and
i think we have to care about the
environment
not even a little bit no do okay let me
let me clarify this
i don't throw trash on the ground like
i'm not saying like
we need to like you know trash the
environment like um but
do i believe in climate change no you
don't believe in climate change well
i think the climate always changes i
guess that's what i say do i believe
that this is like
you know an issue that um is being that
is
global warming which they've changed
conveniently they got rid of the word
once scientists started disproving it
now they
only say client climate change um no i
think that that was just a way to
extract dollars from americans i don't
at all believe they had no actionable
plan it was great for trump to get out
of that deal it was terrible
okay but this is an incredibly
complicated subject
right and if you would have to talk to a
bunch of different scientists and
see how they gather data and see what
they understand about co2 levels and
what's the danger of them
and what can combat it and what could
not have you done all this or
do you take this i'm flippant
this is not this wouldn't be the hill i
died on right but it's not about the
part i just genuinely
i've read a ton about it but i would not
be able to i would not be able to come
to you and say like
this is my strong opinion but here's
like the easiest way to say this right
the fact that there is a disparity in
the science community about whether or
not it's real is enough to
very little very little disparity most
most
most scientists most the vast majority
agree that human beings are negatively
affecting climate change
yeah the vast majority yeah i don't i
just
i just don't think so what i'm trying to
talk about is the totality of evidence
that he has mishandled this pandemic and
it's interesting to me that you were
extremely unwilling to criticize him for
that
because what's the alternative the
alternative what would have happened in
any other circumstance where we have no
we have no control group
what am i supposed to say well wait
right how many would have how many
how many would have had to have died
before you would criticize him
i don't know give me you know wait so
you could have let a million
so what you're telling me is that we
have no idea what would have happened if
trump did anything else
we don't ever suppose we don't
determination that's you're you're
making a tautological statement that's
how the universe works we don't ever
know what would happen
what am i supposed to say when faux
early
early on praised him now they're
critical of him in an election oh wait
wait
first of all the praise of governors is
irrelevant our governor's health experts
second of all
fauci praised him a couple of times he's
also under a lot of political pressure
to do what trump says or otherwise
there's a very
decent chance of him getting canned uh
fauci has made plenty of statements
which trump has later contradicted
trump has been back and forth on the
mask issue going so far as to make fun
of people for wearing
you claim to have like this um a
disaffected
sort of like anti-establishment view of
all of this but you are your channel is
hyper partisan
against the left and then when anyone
criticizes trump you'll either defend
him harshly or you'll back up and say
well they're all bad
you are taking the choice to defend
trump you are the partisan here
you're not a distanced
anti-authoritarian you are standing with
him
and you are saying yes i am
anti-authoritarian i am
anti-establishment
but also we don't know if him lying to
the american people was bad it could
have caused a panic and as a general
rule
i want you david pac-man as a small
business owner which you are with
employees
to pay the least amount of taxes that
you can so that you can hire more people
so that you can build a better studio
so that you can invest more in your
operation
and bring the goodness that is you and
your operation out there
i know this as a small businessman now
if i had been being taxed
higher right now i had massive capital
costs to build this studio
and do all this stuff by the way i pay
100 of my employees health insurance 100
i also give uh my director gets a gets a
cut of our youtube rev
i do all the things i try to put my
beliefs into practice
but that's the confusion for me dave
because
those capital expenses are tax
deductible so if the tax rate goes up
for you as an individual if you've got
pass-through income or for for the
business tax rate
it doesn't matter what the business tax
rate if is if you want to spend money on
capital because
that you don't pay taxes on that
actually it encourages you to spend
money on capital to have a higher tax
rate
um so i under i understand what that
argument is and i would argue at the
same time as that
yeah that having every one of us every
one of us whether you
whether you whatever however much you
earn it is your money
oh no sam cedar what a what what a
[ __ ] nightmare
i had no idea this was going to happen
sam
come on your audience cares that i only
have a million subscribers and you have
what
six or seven million let me answer can i
answer your question can i answer your
question can i answer your question
sure you want me to answer your question
my audience would say sam who
just like joe rogan's audience and ben
shapiro's and dave reuben
because you had to shoot on yourself and
watch this howard's show
every day that you do that yeah i
changed my mind
this is another lie this is another lie
my mind everyone knows on the show right
we've had professors i ended my show
last week stephen if your audience
because you're an idiot
and half of your staff doesn't like my
[ __ ] let's
all
wow dude